Akash I don't know how many of these
Adventures you're going to want to do
I'm a good sport you're an unbelievable
sport I stayed out as late as everybody
else you stayed out as late as everybody
else no no like that's my real time
though that's big mainly because I
didn't know how to get home yeah I was
there though he was there but when y'all
go to the club I'd be like I'm [__]
tuckered out are you trying to get out
of going out so bad but when y'all are
like hey let's go out I'm like
let's go in I still have the country now
I got to see the club the club is a club
is a club he goes oh I'm gonna wear
sweatpants to a club multiple times bro
how are you gonna wear sweatpants to a
club you know they got a dress code why
do you think because in true I got
fashion I tried to pee at a casino
earlier and they wouldn't let me because
I had to pee I found out I couldn't get
in yo dancing with dudes fun I love that
you did like that that was fun you gotta
get some Adventure in you part of it is
going there and experiencing the
enthusiasm of the people getting caught
I know what you mean
but I don't believe it